>>> SINCE TAKING OFFICE,
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS OVERSEEN THE
DISTRIBUTION OF MORE THAN 400
MILLION VACCINE DOSES, THE
RETURN OF 5.8 MILLION JOBS AND
THE RETURN OF ONE OF THE BIGGEST
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE DEALS
IN HISTORY.
BUT COVID IS STILL CIRCULATING,
INFLATION HAS SPIKED AND THE
ANIMOSITY IS TOXIC.
WE WANT TO KNOW HOW VOTERS,
PARTICULARLY INDEPENDENT VOTERS,
FEEL ABOUT THE PRESIDENT'S
HANDLING OF THESE ISSUES.
WE ASSEMBLED A GROUP OF
SELF-DESCRIBED INDEPENDENTS FROM
TENNESSEE, OKLAHOMA, INDIANA,
MICHIGAN AND KANSAS, ALL OF WHOM
HAVE VOTED FOR BOTH DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS IN PAST
PRESIDENTIAL AND STATEWIDE
RACES.
SO HERE NOW IS OUR "PULSE OF THE
PEOPLE."
THE PRESIDENT'S POLL NUMBERS
HAVE GONE FROM I THINK 49%
APPROVAL RATING ON INAUGURATION
DAY.
THEY'VE GONE AS HIGH AT 52%.
NOW THEY'RE DOWN TO 42% AT LAST
COUNT.
WHAT DO YOU BLAME THAT ON?
>> HE INHERITED SOME REALLY
DIFFICULT TIMES, THE PANDEMIC,
OUR ECONOMIC SITUATIONS, THE
DYSFUNCTION IN CONGRESS.
IT JUST IS KIND OF DRAGGING
DOWN, I THINK, AMERICANS'
OPINION OF WHAT'S GOING ON.
AND AS PRESIDENT, THAT ONUS
RESTS ON HIM.
>> WHY DON'T YOU ALL JUST TELL
ME WHAT GRADE YOU WOULD GIVE
PRESIDENT BIDEN TODAY.
>> A "B."
A "B."
IT'S BEEN VERY UNIQUE AFTER THE
INSURRECTION AND STOP THE STEAL
MOVEMENT, WHICH IS REALLY
PRESENT IN OUR HISTORY, AND HE
JUST MAINTAINED A CERTAIN LEVEL
OF SANITY, AND I APPLAUD HIM FOR
THAT.
>> I WOULD SAY A "B."
BETWEEN A "B" AND A "B MINUS."
>> WHAT'S YOUR REASONING?
>> I WOULD DEFINITELY SAY HE HAS
DELIVERED ON MANY PROMISES BUT
SOME OF THEM HE HAS NOT.
HE PROMISED WHEN HE WAS ACTUALLY
RUNNING ON HIS CAMPAIGN TRAIL
THAT HE WOULD WIPE OUT $10,000
WORTH OF STUDENT LOAN DEBT FOR
EVERY INDIVIDUAL THAT HAD
STUDENT LOANS.
THAT HAS YET TO COME TO
FRUITION.
I'M WAITING FOR THAT TO HAPPEN.
>> I GIVE PRESIDENT BIDEN A
SOLID "B-PLUS," MAYBE AN
"A-MINUS."
HE GETS BLAMED FOR WHAT DOES OR
DOESN'T HAPPEN.
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
PANDEMIC.
WE'RE ALL EXHAUSTED.
>> WHAT GRADE DO YOU GIVE
PRESIDENT BIDEN?
>> PROBABLY A "C-PLUS."
HE HAS NOT SHOWN THE PHYSICAL
RESTRAINT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
AT THE SAME TIME HE HAS DONE
WELL AT AT LEAST TRYING TO WORK
IN A BIPARTISAN MANNER.
ONE OF THE THINGS BIDEN HAS DONE
REALLY, REALLY WELL IS LEAD WITH
INTEGRITY AND WITH MATURITY AND
DISCIPLINE.
>> I WOULD PROBABLY GO WITH A
"C-MINUS," BECAUSE HE'S
DEFINITELY AN IMPROVEMENT OVER
THE LAST MAADMINISTRATION.
THERE'S NO DOUBT ON THAT.
BUT I HAVE YET TO SEE ANY
MEANINGFUL ADDRESSING OF OUR
IMMIGRATION ISSUES.
I HAVE YET TO SEE ANY MEANINGFUL
MOVEMENT TOWARD ADDRESSING THE
LOOMING HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
THAT'S COMING.
>> I THINK I WOULD GIVE HIM A
SOLID B.
KIND OF LIKE WHAT ANDY SAID, ON
A GOOD DAY MAYBE A B-PLUS.
>> WHY NOT AN "A"?
WHAT'S KEEPING YOU FROM GIVING
HIM AN "A"?
>> DIFFERENT STAGES OF THE
VACCINE ROLLOUTS, I THINK THERE
WAS JUST SOME POOR
COMMUNICATIONS.
>> SHOW OF HANDS, HOW MANY OF
YOU THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN COULD
BE HANDLING CORONAVIRUS BETTER?
OKAY, TWO OF YOU THINK HE COULD
HAVE BEEN.
SO, AMBER, WHAT COULD HE DO
DIFFERENTLY?
>> I THINK A LOT OF THE PROBLEMS
ARE MISINFORMATION.
AND UNTIL THAT IS ADDRESSED IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY, I DON'T THINK
WE'RE GOING TO SEE A LOT OF
PROGRESS.
>> BUT WHAT COULD HE DO ABOUT
MISINFORMATION?
>> I THINK YOU WOULD HAVE TO
LOOK AT REGULATIONS FOR THINGS
LIKE SOCIAL MEDIA, HAVE HARSHER
PENALTIES.
>> ELAINE, WHAT DO YOU WISH HE
WERE DOING DIFFERENTLY?
>> STAYING OUT OF IT.
I'M SITTING HERE IN WICHITA,
KANSAS AND WE ARE AT MOST 50%
FULLY VACCINATED IN MY COUNTY.
AND WHAT I SEE HERE IN KANSAS IS
I SEE PEOPLE SAYING, WELL, IF A
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT WANTS ME TO
DO IT, THEN ABSOLUTELY NO, I'M
NOT EVEN GOING TO CONSIDER IT.
>> WHEN YOU SAY HE SHOULD HAVE
STAYED OUT OF IT, WHAT WOULD
THAT LOOK LIKE?
>> TURN IT OVER TO LOCAL
PHYSICIANS, TO STATE HEALTH
OFFICERS, STOP COMMENTING, STOP
WITH THE FEDERAL MANDATES.
ANYTHING THAT COMES TO CKANSAS S
A FEDERAL MANDATE FROM A
DEMOCRATIC ADMINISTRATION, OR
EVEN A REPUBLICAN
ADMINISTRATION, IS GOING TO BE
JUST INSTANTLY LAUGHED AT.
>> BETH, YOU'RE IN INDIANA.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT LOGIC?
>> SO I'M GOING TO SPEAK FROM
EXPERIENCE AS A BUSINESS OWNER
WHO HAS A COUPLE OF EMPLOYEES
THAT WILL NOT GET VACCINATED.
THEY ARE BOTH YOUNG, AND SO THEY
BOTH FEEL LIKE IF THEY EVEN GOT
COVID, THEY PROBABLY WOULD NOT
GET SICK, AND IF YOU ARE
VACCINATED, YOU COULD STILL
POTENTIALLY SPREAD THE VIRUS TO
OTHER PEOPLE.
SO WHY DO THEY NEED TO GET THE
SHOT?
THEY JUST FEEL LIKE THEY DON'T
NEED TO GET THE SHOT.
THEY'RE BEING SELFISH, AND THE
MORE THAT PEOPLE GO AT THEM, YOU
NEED TO GET IT, YOU NEED TO GET
IT, THE MORE THEY KIND OF PUSH
BACK ON, NO, I DON'T THINK I DO.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT YOU
THINK ARE THE BIGGEST ISSUES
RIGHT NOW.
>> I THINK THE LABOR SHORTAGE
PROBLEM, JOBS NOT BEING FILLED.
>> WE HAVE OVER $1.75 TRILLION
IN STUDENT LOAN DEBT, SO I WOULD
DEFINITELY SAY THAT.
>> I THINK OUR MOST IMMEDIATE
ISSUE RIGHT NOW IS HOMELESSNESS.
>> I THINK THE BIGGEST ISSUE
FACING AMERICA RIGHT NOW IS THE
THREAT THAT OUR DEMOCRACY FACES.
THE TWO PARTIES HAVE A
STRANGLEHOLD AND I'M GRAVELY
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT OUR
DEMOCRACY WILL HAVE TO GO
THROUGH NEXT YEAR AND IF WE'LL
MAKE IT.
>> I THINK THE BIGGEST THREAT IS
DISINFORMATION AND
MISINFORMATION.
THAT REALLY SCARES ME.
>> YEAH, I THINK THE BIGGEST
THREAT FACING OUR COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW IS PARTISANSHIP.
IT'S THIS PARTISAN DIVIDE, THIS
READ TEAM VERSUS BLUE TEAM, AND
IF I'M ON THIS TEAM, I CAN'T
AGREE WITH ANYTHING THAT THAT
TEAM SAYS.
IT'S TEARING FAMILIES APART,
IT'S TEARING COMMUNITIES APART,
AND I THINK THAT, LIKE ANDY
SAID, THIS IS THE BIGGEST -- OUR
DEMOCRACY IS AT RISK.
>> IF THE ELECTION WERE HELD
TODAY BETWEEN PRESIDENT BIDEN
AND FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP, WOULD YOU STILL VOTE FOR
PRESIDENT BIDEN?
>> YES.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> SO FIVE OF YOU WOULD.
WHAT ABOUT YOU, AMBER?
>> THAT'S A "SOPHIE'S CHOICE"
FOR ME.
IF I HAD TO CHOOSE BETWEEN THE
TWO AND THERE WERE NO OTHER
OPTIONS, I WOULD VOTE FOR BIDEN,
BUT I WOULDN'T BE HAPPY ABOUT
IT.
>> I THINK IT'S INTERESTING,
WHEN YOU HEAR SEVERAL OF THEM
SAY THE BIGGEST PROBLEMS ARE THE
DISINFORMATION AND PARTISANSHIP,
THAT COVERS EVERYTHING.
THAT COVERS, OF COURSE, THE
RESPONSE TO THE PANDEMIC, THE
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES AS WELL.
THOSE TWO ARE PARAMOUNT.
>> ABSOLUTELY, AND I ALSO
THOUGHT IT WAS REALL